that's where I get jumpy
yo beautiful my daughter they went to
the
[Music]
Filipino with cat ran on my chest went
through the code to approach what is
next promise cold as it sneeze you
blessed this is a Walmart we swimming
through biago bees in a nest talking
your honey go to assure me the money
then dip I want the funds in the stock
it's a risk trusting somebody your body
even the savagery has some reality
therefore I couldn't say sorry what an
apology you'll get autopsy before that
I'm killing whatever I get
[Music]
mister
why you bring a kitchen outside of the
kitchen it don't matter kids will do
both daylight difference
so we must appreciate this life we live
in yeah pray for my doors that they went
to the vamp this don't face through the
woods to be vest just respect make
competitions I still know we ain't
through the van or we can't ran on my
chest move through the Cold War poor
choice next promise quote is a sneeze
you blast this is a woman we swimming
through biago peace in the nest I'll get
your honey on the stick go to a sure
make the money then dip I want the funds
in the stock it's a risk trusting
somebody a boy even the savagery has
some reality therefore I couldn't say
sorry what an apology you'll get autopsy
before that I'm killing whatever I get
yeah
sir
hey
[Music]
suicide